So when you're first working with Masry
and you're carrying around this doggedness,
this sticktuitiveness, but your life up to that point
had been a lot of banging your head against a wall
and not really making your way in the manner
in which maybe you envisioned for yourself,
when you get that file and you see that paperwork
about medical records stuck in this, essentially,
a real estate deal,
do you have a conscious sense
of there's an opportunity here for me?
What was your awareness level?
That stuck out but you were a file clerk.
It wasn't your job to go investigate at that point
but there was something that clicked in you that said,
I need to know more, like,
I'm gonna go on a journey with this.
Curiosity, I was smart enough to read the medical reports
and because they were done in a bar graph,
so it didn't take a rocket scientist to figure out
what the hell,
T-cells, what are those?
I looked it up.
So white counts,
what does that mean?
Looked it up.
All of this stuff was off the chart
and mom kicked in and curiosity kicked in and I'm, like,
what if that was my child?
I'd be worried and that's what kicked me off
was just my own,
oh my gosh,
this is weird, I'm curious.
Why would this be happening?
What's wrong with the children?
What would I do if I saw blood work like this on my kid?
That's where I went.
Yeah, in the movie that woman has played
by Marg Helgenberger, right?
Yeah.
But is she a stand-in for a variety of people
or based on a real person?
'Cause in the book,
Roberta.
My sense,
yeah, my sense was that,
in the book she was more up to speed
and more suspicious and knew more.
It plays in the movie like she's less suspecting
of what's happening.
Well, if you remember in the movie,
when Julia first meets her is Roberta Walker and
she knew enough because she was already asking questions.
That's why I was there.
And you see her connect the dots in the conversation.
And she goes,
my God, the water,
the kids, the pool.
Roberta was already there.
Where she looks out and her kids are swimming
in the pool at the time.
Right.
And that's how I got involved,
beginning with Roberta's persistence.
And like I told you,
in every community there's a Roberta Walker.
Yeah.
There is an Erin Brockovich.
Oh, they're there.
And then when they joined forces,
we started really getting some stuff done.
I still talk to Roberta all the time.
I was just on text with her the other day.
She's amazing and she's one of those moms
and she was done with the bullshit
and she'd been pushed through enough.
You know, we talk about in the book,
when people come to me,
like even more Roberta,
when she first came to the law firm,
in a way they're looking for permission,
if you will,
to act and what they really need is support.
And when I showed up and I'm, like,
oh hell, yeah,
no, I wouldn't deal with this if this was my kids.
I mean, it starts there.
The support starts there.
And this is something that was really well thought out
to keep covered up.
And so the community,
they didn't know who to listen to.
And then once we got together,
it's amazing what happens 'cause nobody ever wants
to be the first to say it.
And we don't wake up every day and ask our neighbor,
did little Johnny get diagnosed with colitis?
And have you been having chronic nosebleeds and weight loss?
We don't do that.
And once we started getting Roberta come to the firm,
I go out there,
Roberta and I together and then calling another mom
and another mom, very quickly,
we became a bigger group.
And I talk about that in the book, logic,
common sense, leverage.
People think leverage is a bad thing.
No, it's not.
That's getting to know your neighbor.
The minute we started leveraging ourselves
with the community,
PG&E ignored us with one and five and 10,
but when we became 50, 200,
500, 600,
they're going, what's going on
out here?
Right.
And that creates an environment
where a whistleblower might feel more inclined
to disclose what he or she knows.
I mean, in the movie,
the Fisher Stevens character,
short of getting his documents,
it would have been a different story, right?
Absolutely.
So you need the groundswell
but you also need those people on the inside
who might be willing to share with you something
that you're not gonna be able to find otherwise.
Well, you do and you're absolutely right.
And Roberta Walker had already been to the water board
and she had made a note on one of her notes and I'm, like,
what's this CR-VI?
And she said, oh,
there's chromium VI.
So she was already on it.
So when I went into the water board,
that's when I started seeing the documents
like the one I just shared with you.
So oftentimes the documents are there.
On the intake somebody may or may not know what they are
and files them and they're never discovered again.
Or somebody, clearly will make a reference,
put this over here,
don't bring it out again.
So there's a whole lot of factors that happen
and there is a whistleblower,
they will make a phone call.
You've gotta go find a document.
And in a lot of these communities,
now they'll come to me and we'll go in with some documents.
I can see when the light bulb comes on and I'm, like,
yes, okay.
This community is ready to roll.
Now we're gonna go over here because they will catch on.
And they're usually pissed.
And I actually hope if people read the book,
when they close it,
you get mad too and realize that you too can do exactly.
The women of Tonganoxie, Kansas,
they ran Tyson out on a rail.
The women at Hannibal, Missouri,
they ran for office and won.
My gosh, in Flint,
Michigan, right now we have the youngest gentleman
on city council,
19 years old.
Do not think for one minute just because you don't
have a PhD or you're a stay-at-home mom,
or you're a cocktail waitress somewhere,
or you're working as a law clerk that everyone thinks
'cause you have stilettos on and blonde hair
and big boobs you're stupid.
We shouldn't be underestimating people.
You can do this.
Find your 'cause,
whatever it may be and it may not be water.
You need the tips,
the strategy and the tools to fight.
Learn them and game on and you can do it.
And I'm telling you,
the first step you take and you get just a little bit
of that win or you're like,
oh my gosh, I understand this.
Oh my gosh,
I got such and such a neighbor to talk to me,
and you see it, it's contagious.
And the momentum builds.
It's very empowering that you can fix or change a law
or get involved or get noticed or get on a Superfund site
or get information to a doctor and see what's happening.
Change
in your own backyard.
I love
We do that.
It's so exciting.
We, the people.
I think we, the people,
have forgotten to believe in we, the people.
And I know we get like overwhelmed, fricking fatigue.
I'm with you but I can pass on a lot of fights.
We are water.
We are sustained by water.
Do not think that we might not have water,
especially if we keep going at this rate,
and let's get serious about climate change.
And we talk about climate change in the book.
And we talk about Johannesburg, South Africa,
where they literally were going to have Day Zero.
Yeah, that was
Day Zero.
But here's what
they did, what we're not doing,
and where we can learn from.
The people responded.
The people were involved.
The people rationed.
They did what they had to do.
The agencies responded.
They became prepared and they diverted
Day Zero.
We've got to get and stop the argument.
I don't care what side of the aisle you're on.
This is all of our issues.
We need to work together.
We need to be informed.
We need to be prepared and we can divert,
and there are solutions to these issues,
the problem is we won't get busy doing them.
And that's where we have to go.
We, as a consumer cannot take anything for granted anymore.
And I do believe that we, the people,
have an absolute obligation to ourselves
and to our family and to our communities
to make it our job to find out and be informed,
and there's no reason why you shouldn't be,
and to act and to find your own courage and not be afraid
to step up and get involved.
Because Superman is not coming.
No but tag, yeah,
you're here, we're it.
(Rich chuckling)
Yes.
Powerful Erin Brockovich
in the house.
Thank you so much.
I do want to share with you,
it was great to have this conversation.
'Cause, you know,
when I go to parties and people ask me about water
and it turns into this conversation,
I'm telling you,
I know what they say when I leave.
They're like, oh my God,
don't invite her again.
Are you kidding?
People are gonna freak out.
They're gonna love this.
I know it's overwhelming.
I feel it too.
You can come back and we could talk for two hours
just about PHAS.
Absolutely.
People will love it.
But you know what?
I will share with this and my program RAM,
realize, assess and motivate.
It's all one's self.
Realize who you are,
assess who you are.
Look, oftentimes we look for a hero
and the only person standing in your own way
of being that hero is,
frankly, you.
And we all get that little negative voice in our head
that tells us, do this,
don't do that.
Realize that you can have that strength and courage,
you can find it.
Assess, don't assess your bank account.
Just assess who you are,
what's your character?
What's your loyalty?
What's your respect?
What's your cause?
What's your passion?
And what I wanted to say here is,
we do live in a crazy world.
I'm thinking my head's gonna spin off,
I really do.
And it's just going faster and faster and faster and faster.
And what's happening for us as people,
we're losing our mojo and we've lost our motivation
and we are, frankly, exhausted.
And what you need to do when you hit that wall,
and you will as you move into whatever your causes are,
and it may not be water,
you got to know how to fight and you gotta have the tools.
One of the tools that you have to do is self-renewal.
We're all on our computers, right,
and when a bunch of data comes in or an overload,
what do you get?
The blue dot just spins and spins.
That theme really irritates me.
That happens to us.
That's when you need to disconnect.
You must do it.
And
get back to a walk on the beach.
Get back to a hike.
Get outside and plant begonias.
Go play a round of golf.
Disconnect
and reconnect to yourself.
It's amazing when you do that you can hear yourself think.
You can feel yourself feel.
(Erin inhaling)
You can take
(Erin exhaling)
a moment to breathe and get clarity.
And when you do,
that self-renewal, you'll find yourself waking
up the next day with some motivation and energy
to go at it again.
(dramatic swishing)
How do you feel about
this later chapter
in the McConaissance of you becoming like this guru,
you know, this person of wisdom that I don't know
when it began,
maybe it began when you gave that commencement speech.
But at some point you kind of went from Matthew,
the actor, into somebody who
was basically imparting life lessons
to the world.
How do you think about that or how do you feel about that?
Was that intentional or is it just a by-product
of who you are?
I think it started off more of a by-product
and then has gained some intention along the way.
To go back to that,
it's live, we're all in the show,
the recording, the camera's always recording.
And to say,
ask myself, are you making legacy choices
for yourself right now, McConaughey?
Are you
living in a way, live,
that is useful for yourself and others?
Look, I'll say this.
I go back to the University of Texas
and I had an idea for this Script to Screen class
as a professor.
But in my mind I'm still, like,
I'm talking to the students.
I feel like I was there the other day.
But then I start sharing things with them
and they're going, like,
whoa, that's awesome.
Thank you for telling me that.
I'm like, oh that wasn't obvious?
And they're like, no,
we didn't know that.
And so I started to go,
well, wait a minute,
you got 28 years of experience of acting
and being on sets, Matthew.
Oh geez, that's right,
add that up.
You do have some experience that may be innate to you now
that is novel to a student.
So you do have something to share,
some experience to share
that maybe someone else didn't have.
The share in this book has got quite a few tools
in it for how to find our frequency individually,
and hopefully, as a collective
We're going through a time right now of great distrust.
We don't know what to believe in.
You don't trust others.
You all of a sudden look up,
you don't trust yourself.
And that little revolution can go back and forth.
Well, now I don't trust myself,
now I really don't trust you.
Now I don't believe in myself,
now I don't believe in anything.
And those are dead end streets, ultimately.
So how do we rebuild some trust?
I think is through values.
I think values are bipartisan and non-denomination.
I think those are the solid stepping stones
that we need to each look in the mirror
and ask ourselves how we can be better out on a daily basis?
And that'll be incremental steps out of this time
into hopefully a more evolved state that we get out of
and help us look back at 2020 as a actual Red Banner year
of recreation and recreation and a new beginning.
We gotta remember we're never gonna arrive.
There's not a destination, man.
It's like our lives
and say, America,
the Langston Hughes poem, "America".
Yet,
that's what we should be chasing,
yet.
We never get there.
With the social cultural revolution we're going on,
we're not gonna get to perfect justice.
But if we can make an incremental ascension forward,
that's it, stay in the race,
commit to the chase.
And with ourselves,
can we just keep chasing our better selves a little bit
and know we're gonna screw up along the way.
Can America just keep,
we're an aspiration.
Our lives are an aspiration.
America is an aspiration.
It's a chasing of, yet.
And I think that's what we ultimately are as individuals,
we all should be chasing ourselves.
What more fun, wild,
adventurous thing to chase in your life than yourself?
Well, there's an unbridled optimism to that
that's infectious and that I love
and I don't wanna take up too much of your time.
We can end it on this.
I can't let you go without digging a little bit more deeply
into kind of where we're at
in this American experiment right now?
We're headed into an election.
We are extremely divided.
Communities, families,
individuals are having difficulty finding common ground,
being able to even effectively communicate.
And there is this
layer of whether it's fake news
or misinformation that's confusing people
and driving us apart.
And I have this sense of us fracturing
and I'm trying to figure out how to get my hands around it,
how I can communicate with my brothers and my sisters,
how I can be more empathetic?
How can we look to what unites us to our commonalities
which are so much more robust than the details
that might divide us on paper or on social media?
But I find myself concerned about what I'm seeing
and where we're heading.
So how do we right this ship, Matthew?
Great question.
(chuckling)
So problem for me,
for us?
Oh wow, yeah right.
I was talking about it earlier, yeah,
it is times of great distrust in others and ourselves.
Our social contracts are broken.
Our personal contracts are broken.
We don't have expectations of ourselves or others.
Right now the private sector,
down to the individual has more power than ever.
We can't trust our leadership.
Politics is a broken business.
What do we want?
And people want security.
Well, we're all individuals.
Wait a minute,
where's the collective?
All this is being politicized along the way.
The body counts are being added up for which side
of the aisle wants to win?
And that's the only numbers each side's counting.
We've got an election year.
Are we gonna have a civil war?
Man, can we just get to January 2021,
which is a symbolic day,
but nothing more than a symbolic day.
Do we have a ten-year restoration?
Do we have a 20-year restoration?
I don't know how long it'll go.
What can we rely on?
Empathy, one thing.
A little amnesty right now.
It's a tough time for everybody.
I don't know how to make a collective change.
I don't know how to make an overall systemic change
or a law.
I don't think people wanna be legislated like that.
I think it, again,
comes down to each one of us need to look in the mirror.
You go, how can I be a little bit better?
What can I do a little bit better?
I don't have to be great.
I don't have to be perfect.
There is no best.
How can I be a little bit better?
How can I be a little more fair?
How can I understand that my brother
and sister are also hurting,
maybe in more and different ways than I am?
How can I have a conversation without a condemnation?
How can I have more patients to take a breath and listen
and let someone who hasn't been heard speak
more loudly than maybe they need to,
but hear them?
How do we make this time not just a flash in the pan?
How do we be honest with the choices we make for ourselves,
selfishly, are also the best choices
for the most amount of people?
And then there's not any specific recipe for that
but take that into consideration
when we make our choices for ourselves.
Again, responsibility and freedom,
we're gonna have to build our way out of this time.
We're gonna have to break a damn sweat for a while.
And I think we have to have that long view
that feeling like this is gonna go on for a while.
Now, how can we make that a part of our daily instincts
of how we go about our lives?
How do we treat ourselves?
How do we treat our loved ones?
How do we treat our employees?
How do we treat people we work with?
How do we treat what we're building?
Are we just for profit or are we for purpose as well?
What's our purpose?
I'm not interested in politics,
I'm interested in some purpose though.
Politics is a broken business.
We don't know who to trust so that's what I mean
by the private sector,
down to the individual.
You have more power right now
to define your future than ever,
because you actually don't have anyone else up there,
no institution to rely on for that guidance.
So understand that, man.
Some of us are going, well,
what the hell, man,
give me a map.
I don't know what to trust in.
I don't know what's a consensus here.
Some of us are gonna do well right now
'cause we can just keep our head above the water.
Just try and make it through this time.
It's going pass.
We're gonna be moving forward.
We are not turning the page yet though.
When the time comes to turn the page on COVID,
when the time comes to turn the page
on the culture revolution,
the only way it's gonna work is if the collective,
all of us,
every color, if you've got COVID,
if you don't,
every color of skin,
do it together to some form or fashion.
I think as much as we are a nation of individuals
and love our individualism,
we
are failing at any sort
of collective responsibility.
We have failed with the mask of seeing
that as a civic duty instead of a, damn,
don't you tell me what to do bullshit.
It's the wrong kind of selfish.
It's actually not a selfish move to fight those fights.
There is a responsibility that we can choose to take
for and with each other and ourselves,
and those two are not exclusive.
My hunch is it lies in the values.
My hunch is it lies in responsibility, accountability,
risk-taking, sense of humor.
The list goes on and on and on.
And we can just be a little kinder,
a little more fair,
a little more empathetic,
a little more understanding,
a little more forgiving,
also holding on to accountability.
This isn't gonna be a free ride.
I'm not in for a world Kumbaya.
No, it's gonna take work.
And the greatest thing about America is
when America's working right is
if you're willing to work at something
and educate yourself and go after something,
you more so than anywhere else should have the opportunity
to achieve that,
but not without the work and the education
and the hustle to go do it.
I'd say this, man,
start off with trying to create more green lights
for yourself and others and see where those two meet,
and see that actually being selfless
is actually a very selfish act.
Creating more for others is actually very selfish
for yourself as well,
and make sure you're trying
to make sure your selfish choices
for yourself also light the way for more people as well.
(dramatic swooshing)
How do you think about the difference
between failure and success?
(dramatic swooshing)
Often, luck.
(Shane chuckling)
I don't know.
I mean, I've had a lot of failure.
I'll let you know when I get some success but
I think from a decision-making point of view,
the decisions where you know the outcome
or you can't fail are not really worth thinking about.
And you have to determine
if failure is something you can handle or not.
And often we are going to fail
and how do we recover from that is super important
to achieving success.
Because the odds that you succeed the first time
you try something are pretty slim.
If you look at, like,
we're all walking today and we fell down walking hundreds,
if not thousands of times,
but we got up and we did it again.
And so often life is just getting
up one more time than you fall down.
But going back to decision-making again, reversible,
irreversible, like where can you fail,
where can you fail?
And how we think about what failure means,
I think we attach so much meaning to it
and there's so much ego that is infused into that.
We're afraid to look bad.
We don't wanna appear to have failed to our peers
and things like that that prevent us
from perhaps being more open about taking certain risks
that could in the longterm create
a better and bigger growth curve.
Well, that goes back to sort of how we're living our life.
Like, who's scorecard are we using?
Are we using an internal scorecard
or we're using an external scorecard?
Am I failing to meet up to somebodies expectations of me?
Is that something I wanna do or do I want freedom?
And the freedom in this case would be freedom
from living up to other people's expectations,
freedom from sort of
feeling the need to fulfill society's obligations to me.
And I'm not saying break the law or anything like that
but we're so often driven by, you're
subliminally and otherwise told
that the people who attain power,
money and fame are sort of the people to emulate.
Like, my kids come home from school
and they start talking about all these celebrities.
I'm like, man,
I want you home talking about like Richard Feynman
and Albert Einstein.
These are the heroes, right.
Like Elan, not these political sort of people
or not these Hollywood movie stars.
I don't want them in that life where they see
that as success because that leads to
how do I get that success which leads to,
I can step on other people,
I can do these things that are mutually exclusive
from living a life of meaning
in order to try to attain these things.
And I think that we know, I mean,
that that's not the path that we want our kids on.
And who we have as our heroes is super important
too.
Right,
heroes walk amongst us.
We just don't do a great job of shining a light
on the best ones.
And in order to do that,
you have to do a little counter-programming against
what mainstream society is feeding all of us,
not just young people.
But I think some of that comes from just,
we were talking about this earlier, reflection right.
Where do I wanna go in life?
And that comes from being alone with your thoughts
and working through your thoughts
and having many false steps in sort
of being conscious about am I working towards those goals
or my not working towards them?
Is this where I actually wanna end up?
Because so many of us reach our destination and we're, like,
oh, this isn't what I thought it was.
This isn't where I wanted to go.
And part of the problem is we didn't check in on the way
and maybe that's a weekly check-in.
I mean, I do it sort of twice a year at this point,
but maybe it's monthly.
Maybe it's sort of like something,
you book a holiday with yourself for a day every year
and you sort of go to this isolated area
where you're not around people and maybe you walk
in nature or maybe you sit in a hot tub
or you do whatever you need to do.
And you think about,
am I living the life that I wanna be living?
What are the things that I'm doing that are leading me
to where I wanna go?
What are the things that are getting in the way
of where I wanna go?
And what would I regret if I died today?
Is there a relationship that I wanna repair?
Is there somebody that's not serving me
that I need to get rid of because I don't like their anger?
Those are the questions that we can sort
of walk through mentally.
And then we start,
once you realize it then you put it into action.
As you said at the start,
action's really hard, right?
You might have a really close friend who's always angry
and it's affecting you and it's affecting your health.
But at the end of the day you know you need to let them go
because they're not gonna get you where you wanna go
and you can't help them.
What does that daily practice look like for you?
I think a lot like that.
I mean, I don't do daily.
I have regular scheduled appointments with myself
to make sure that I do it.
But I'm always thinking about,
like, how can I help this person?
And at some point you can't help them
and you need to sort of,
your environment will dictate a large part
of where you go in life.
So who you hang around,
how much you care about other people dictates,
I mean, to a large extent how fulfilled
and meaningful your life is.
So yeah, I mean,
everybody has their own routine.
There's no one prescription for it
and there's no wrong answer to it.
It's just, I think that if there was a wrong answer,
it would be like I'm just not thinking about it
because it's hard, right.
It's hard to be like,
I don't wanna be where I'm at.
It's hard to absolve or hard to take responsibility
for being in that spot, right.
And we're all born into a set of circumstances
that we don't control.
We don't control sort of our parents' socioeconomic status.
We don't control our zip code.
We don't control how much they care.
We don't control the trajectory we're put on.
But at some point in life you take control
of that trajectory and maybe it's 18 for some people,
maybe it's 25 for other people,
but at that point you're in control.
So you don't control what point you're at
but you control where you go from there.
And you do that through your habits.
You do that through your thinking.
You do that through your decision-making.
And the question that I want everybody to ask is,
where am I going?
Am I gonna get there?
Is what I'm doing today gonna get me where I wanna go?
And if not,
what do I need to do in order to get where I wanna go?
I'm here listening to you and I'm, like,
this is amazing.
And I'm also,
I'm noticing my resistance also
because I'm, like,
this guy's trying to write a computer program, you know.
An operating
system for life.
For living,
you know what I mean?
I'm a very emotional, sensitive person.
I'm like, where does intuition,
where does that
spark where you
I'm a huge believer.
Don't know where it came from and you're, like,
I'm channeling something where I don't even know
from whence it arrives.
Is there a place for that kind of spirituality
to live in the work that you do?
Totally, I believe that that's a huge component
into our lives, right.
I don't believe in just pure rationality.
I don't think that's the way we should live lives.
And I think that emotion and sort of spirituality
and community and all of those things are also part
of it, right.
We're part of an ecosystem but individually
we have emotions.
We need to sort of
not deny them,
not suppress them, right.
I think so many problems in society today,
from my vantage point,
is people over analyzing their feelings,
trying to suppress them and not actually feeling them,
delaying the feeling instead of just being present
with the emotions.
There's a lot of studies that say
if you actually feel the feelings when you first feel them
they sort of last 90 seconds to sort of three minutes.
Like if you're angry and you don't suppress it
and you don't sort of analyze it
and you just feel that anger,
it'll go away pretty quickly.
But it's when you suppress it that it starts
to crop up again and you become passive aggressive
and then you become aggressive, aggressive.
And
I think that we need to feel those feelings.
And there's decisions that you're gonna make
in life that are not rational and that's okay, right.
They don't have to be rational.
I think what you wanna do is just be aware
that you're conscious of the fact
that you're not making a rational decision
or you're okay sort of throwing the rational side
of your brain out.
Like quitting a great high-profile job to start a blog
is not necessarily the most rational decision you can make.
Who you marry,
who you're in relationship with,
what that connection is like,
those are not purely rational decisions.
Those are very emotionally-driven chemistry,
physiological response-based decisions.
And I think that those are equally powerful,
if not in some cases more powerful
than rational decision-making.
Yeah, I think they can be channeled to great effect
as long as you have a healthy understanding
of that emotional landscape.
Like, when am I feeling a spark of inspiration
or when am I experiencing some kind of overwhelming emotion
that I know is driving me towards making a certain type
of decision versus,
oh, I'm just repeating a pattern as a result
of my childhood trauma.
This is gonna take me down the wrong path.
Even though I feel strongly about doing this,
I know well enough to know that
that's not the right thing to do.
But so often that becomes an excuse today too, right.
We sort of, like,
oh, I was brought up that way.
But going back to what I said.
This is what I do.
This is what I do, right.
So we tell ourselves that narrative
and that narrative becomes reality
when another narrative you can replace that with.
And often we have to replace narratives to get sort
of better narratives is that I'm in control of my life
and no matter what's happened to me,
it might not be my fault that I'm in this situation
but it's my responsibility
how I handle this situation going forward.
It's my responsibility to respond to the situation
in the best way that I can.
And I own that and nobody else owns that for me
and I can't blame my past.
But everything in my past has got me here
and that's okay.
The past has put you on this trajectory.
It's put you at this moment in time.
Where you go from here is completely up to you though
and you control that and nobody else controls that.
Boom, powerfully said.
(dramatic swooshing)
In the fairness versus inclusion conversation,
it's not a matter of tipping the scales
towards inclusion over fairness.
You're thinking that these things can co-exist
and that it's not problematic?
Absolutely, and I think transgender women
and girls have been competing with women
and girls for years without problem,
with their peers.
And they've been participating on sports teams
at the high school level,
at the elite level and there has been no problems, right.
And I think that what
the discrimination against transgender women
and girls actually does is takes away from the real issue
about the disparity in sport and the gender inequity
that exists in sport.
What we really should be focusing on is women's sports
and how we uplift women's sports.
And I think that targeting transgender women
does not do that.
It doesn't help.
The real problem is the lack of access,
the lack of resources,
the pay inequity that exists within women sports
because of systemic discrimination.
Yeah, well certainly that's for real.
I've just put up a couple podcasts that kind
of go pretty deep into that.
I mean, that's a huge problem.
In the track and field context,
are there transgender women who are killing it?
No.
Their aren't?
Tell me what (indistinct) means?
I didn't do any research on this so I actually don't know.
Track and field is the one area that
when people are talking about this across the country
they're looking at two transgender girls in Connecticut
who are high school student athletes
who last year went one,
two at state.
When we're talking about dominating
when they went to nationals,
one didn't even compete and the other placed 30th
and 31st in her two races.
Okay.
And so, yes,
they have won races,
but dominating is inaccurate.
Right.
And I think that people really pick up on those stories
and these are two young black women.
And I bring up race again
because race is absolutely a part of this.
Being a transgender woman is absolutely a part of this.
Women in sports,
both cisgender and trans have had their bodies policed
for years, for decades.
And it's by targeting transgender women
and focusing on people's bodies,
I think, that we really perpetuate
that issue within women sports.
What happens in track and field,
I mean, the case study that gets brought
up conflates intersex because it's all
about Caster Semenya, right,
and whether or not she should be allowed to compete.
And that brings up a different kind of ripple
in the fairness versus inclusion conversation,
because this is a human being
who was just born a certain way, right.
And so, should she be unable to compete and penalized
because this is how the universe or God,
or whatever you want to call it,
made her in a certain way?
I can't proclaim to have the answer to that
but it's an interesting conversation that needs to be had.
Yeah, absolutely.
And I think it's really important that we remember
that there's not one way to be a man.
There's not just one way to be a woman.
And there are certainly categories that they have
for hormones at the elite level of testing, right.
But there's not just one way to be a trans person either.
And there's not just one way to have a body
that excels in sport.
So the body that a swimmer would have is going
to be different than what would be helpful
for an elite sprinter or a rower.
So when we make these generalizations
about trans women dominating a sport
or someone like Caster Semenya,
having her make-up being able to dominate in sport,
I think that we reach real dangerous territory.
And what's the vision that you hold,
like four years,
10 years from now,
where would you like to see the state of culture and sport?
And we can kind of wrap it up with that,
I think, right?
Yeah.
Where is this going if it was up to you?
I think that sport is one of the most magical places
for people to exist.
I think that sport is a vehicle for social change
and the change that happens within sports
in terms of policies and acceptance
and inclusion can really be a guide
for the rest of the world.
And we've seen it in the past.
And I think that we're at a crossroads right now
where how we treat inclusion in sport is going
to reflect in the rest of society.
Yeah, absolutely.
I mean, I think I read somewhere that you were inspired
by some of the great activist athletes out there.
I don't know who in particular,
but there's these iconic images that come to mind
from Muhammad Ali to
the closed, gloved fist on the podium at the Olympics
and the ability of the athlete to move culture forward
and advance conversation around ideas
that people are resistant to is a thing.
And I think that you're somebody who is on
the sort of razor's edge of this
in a new and broader
conversation around civil rights
and what that means and what kind of culture
and society do we wanna be in and live in.
And I think your advocacy is admirable
and I'm in awe of your athletic talent
and also your strength and your courage
to put yourself out there
in harm's way, I think,
in a very real way.
You're putting yourself at peril to get this message across
and that may get lost in the conversation
but I would imagine that that's a very real consideration
for you as well, your safety.
So it's important work that you're doing
and I wish you all the best and thank you for what you do.
Thank you.
Athletes have a platform and I think that athletes
have social capital not just in the United States,
but in the world.
And we look at Olympians differently.
We look at professional athletes differently.
We even look at high school
and collegiate athletes differently.
And so I think it's an incredible position
for me to be in to have this platform,
to have a Nike sponsorship
and things like the New York Times article
and to be able to express to people the concerns
about the realities facing transgender people,
not just in sport,
but in our community as a whole.
I want people to know that they can be their authentic self
and continue to play the sports that they love
and continue to do their passions and not have
to compromise any part of their identity,
to hide any part of their identity.
Because when we are authentic about who we are
and when we are able to,
and it's not safe for everyone to come out,
but if we are able to do that,
your entire world opens up and it not just impacts you
but impacts the people around you.
And I think that's really how social change is created,
is that ripple effect.
And so my hope is that me waking up every single day
and living an awesome life can be my advocacy.
And that all the other parts I have
to talk about are a part of that,
but I really just want people to see that I am possible,
that they are possible because I am possible and
nothing is off limits,
people can have a future,
the future that I didn't see for myself
when I was younger, it exists.
And for the person who's listening,
who's living
a secret double life or just is afraid to come out,
what is the kind of message that you would like
to impart to that person?
Yeah, there are so many factors that go in
to one's ability to come out.
And it's now with laws and policies like this
about access to care and safety.
There are financial concerns and family support concerns
for young people.
There are very real possibilities
that people will lose their house
or their apartment and the housing,
their employment and things like that.
And so there are so many factors that go in to it
that I would never tell somebody that they have to come out.
And I think this is one of the problems that we have
in professional sports is we're looking for that out gay,
male athlete in the big four sports.
When are they going to come out?
There are so many factors
in any LGBTQ plus person's existence
of whether or not to come out.
My messages is to that person would just be
that they are valid and their identity is valid
and real and that they are worthy of love
and respect and dignity.
(dramatic swooshing)
There's so much beauty in suffering.
And I know it sounds so,
it's not a cliche,
but it's people are scratching their head,
how can there be beauty in suffering?
When you go through the suffering that a lot of us have
that have been on this show that have become successful,
is because when you go through that suffering,
you go through such a darkness,
you go through such a
bottom feeder kind of exposure that
you learn to have gratitude for the smallest thing,
the smallest thing.
And
when I think about
the times when
I didn't think that I was gonna really make it
out of that space,
there were times, Rich,
when I would be in the car park of Whole Foods
crying,
crying my heart out,
screaming at the top of my lungs,
looking around, like,
how the fuck did I end up in this situation?
One of the stories that I always tell people,
and it's a story
but it's a story that I often tell people
because mental health and suicide is so big.
And I know in this day and age it's being amplified
and people are talking about it but
when you hit a certain level of
suffering and you think there is nothing else,
you can look back at these times
in that darkness and be, like,
man, if I didn't know the depths and the levels
of darkness I wouldn't be able
to enjoy this moment right now.
So there was a time when
I used to pack a gun with me everywhere.
Orlando used to be,
and Orlando still kind of has a very,
you've got the Disney side and you got the super rough,
like home invasions,
like they'll come and run your house,
they'll shoot you in the middle of Walmart.
That's like Florida, right?
Right.
(Rich laughing)
Sometimes I pray for my kids still out there, but still.
Florida is a state
where you have your stand-your-ground law.
So you can come in to somebody's residence
and they can shoot you on self-defense and
that's it.
It's called stand-your-ground or the castle law.
Which is interesting in light of what's going on
with Brianna Taylor right now.
Yeah. Right.
To think about that.
And then also you mentioned to me that the cop
who put his knee on George Floyd's neck
now is living down the street
from your daughters?
Or was living
down the street, yeah,
from my kids,
yeah, in Florida.
That's insane.
Yeah, which that's a whole nother story in itself.
But just to bring it back to this,
that was such a dark, dark time.
For me, I used to pack because
where my parents live it's not a rough neighborhood
but there was a lot of home invasions.
There was a lot of break-ins.
My parents are all old.
And again, remember I told you had to move back
in with my parents?
Mhmm.
Well, after couch surfing and yada yada.
Back again, after the divorce
Bro.
Back in.
37, 38.
(laughing)
So this is the umteenth time I'm moving back
with my parents.
My relationship with my parents now,
I used to be scared of them,
I used to fear them.
Now, I don't like my brother and sister.
The relationship is amazing.
This this last stint with my parents,
and for them to see how broken I was
was really, really deep.
And to cry with your parents is even deeper.
And I don't know if you've ever had that,
but when you're in the presence of your mother
or your father and you are legit all crying in despair,
it's a hard,
hard pill to swallow, man.
And it was.
And it was hard to come home knowing that I lost everything.
And it was hard knowing to come home that I had three kids
that I'm still paying for,
that I'm still paying for that school.
I'm still paying for everything and I can't talk to them
because she won't let me talk to them.
So all this stuff is going down.
Meanwhile, I'm still paying for the house.
I'm still paying for the minivan.
I'm still paying for all their extra curricular activities.
And I'm at home at my parents' house
(Hakim snickering)
with a shotgun underneath the bed.
(Hakim laughing)
Crying in the parking lot
of Whole Foods.
Crying in the parking lot.
I mean, did you have a sense,
this idea that
you can't be a phoenix
without the ashes, right?
Like, this idea that you're being burned for a reason,
that there's a purpose or that there's something
to be mined and learned from this experience
so that you can emerge more fully integrated.
I mean, with all of this spiritual education behind you,
you must've been able to hold on to some aspect of that
or to believe or to choose to believe
that there is some kind of purpose or lesson
to be learned here,
to be making?
I did but it was
very little in the grand scheme of things.
It was very little because although I had the running
that kind of took me out of that space, right,
because I would run.
And my running was then,
that becomes your new
healing modality?
That becomes my
new healing mechanism, right.
So I had to running that became my new healing mechanism
and I could grab onto that.
And I still had my spiritual faculties
but I wasn't leaning onto them as much as I could.
So in that interim
I had
my friends.
I have a really good girlfriend of mine.
Her name is Christina.
My ex-wife was named Christina
and my best friend was Christina at the time.
Christina was the first person that I went to when I got,
essentially, out the house and I was couch surfing.
She looked after me basically for two summers
because I was broke.
And she looked off to me for two summers along
with my parents and really kind
of helped me get back on track.
And then, as I said,
because in that time I'd probably contemplate suicide four
or five times.
And the one story that I was trying to bring up
and I really bring this story was the story was me
in the parking lot of Orlando Zen Center.
A friend of mine, Sandra Bianca.
Love Sandra.
Sandra was the one who said,
you need something.
Come to the temple.
At the time I didn't know what the temple was.
She said, come to the temple.
I was like, okay.
So I drive up there
and I got this big Springfield 45 next to me.
And at the time I had just got off the phone with my ex.
We had just gone into a major argument,
she's asking for more money for the house.
I'm literally just shaking and I'm just
shaking uncontrollably and I'm, like,
do I just do it right now?
I'm looking at the gun.
I'm in front of the temple.
And then I'm, like,
all right, fuck it.
I'm gonna go do whatever this fucking thing is.
I don't know what I'm gonna get into but I'm gonna do it.
That could've been my last day on the earth
and instead I chose to sit in front of a wall in silence
for an hour and a 1/2.
That's heavy, man.
(dramatic swooshing)
The important thing for all of us is
that we wanna just stay healthy
and get through this with the energy
and the strength that we currently have.
And hopefully you can build upon
that versus deteriorate in any way.
And not even from a virus standpoint
and the concerns with that but also just
because this time requires so much extra energy
in everything we're doing,
from homeschooling to everybody and being in the house
and patients and so forth.
I mean, me with four kids here at home,
and all of them teenagers,
you can just imagine how they're all staring at me going,
you gotta be kidding me.
We're so sick and tired of you.
(Chris laughing)
And so they're being healthy,
getting enough sleep, eating well,
and having some sort of physical outlet every day
makes a huge difference on having the patience
and perspective for them,
because it's difficult for them currently too.
And also, it's going to be of memory for all of us,
regardless how it hit us,
whether in a positive way,
in a negative way.
That's the unique thing about this.
It hit the brakes on the entire world
and we're all gonna all remember this forever.
Our teenagers, our younger children,
us as adults, 20-somethings,
30-somethings, everybody has been impacted by this.
Everybody's going to remember this time, right.
And people have been saying it's our 9/11 moment
or this and that,
but it has hit so many more
spectrums of society.
And there's a lot of ways we don't control,
we don't know how it hits everybody,
so all we know is how it hits us.
Doesn't mean we don't have empathy and care
and respect for those who are working through this
and healthcare workers and those who've been hit by tragedy
or those who are losing their jobs and so forth,
but it hits every one of us individually.
And so what are we going to do with it?
And that's what we said earlier is
how do we want to kick out of this,
but also, how do we make it memorable?
And it's going to be memorable either way.
So if that is going to be memorable either way,
how do we want it to be a memorable,
in a positive, meaningful,
caring, thoughtful,
family-sharing, joyous way?
For others it's not,
it's not going to be that.
But we don't control that.
I was reminded of that Viktor Frankl quote, right.
"If you can't change or control the external circumstances,
"change yourself, or your own internal circumstances."
This is one of those times that
we only control us and how we present ourselves
to the world.
And part of that is this,
whether it's family,
whether that's work,
whether it's our loved ones,
whether that's our body and how we go about our day
and carry ourselves as that beacon of strength
and support and outward love to others.
Yeah, I can think of only a handful of other
moments in my life where the world sort of stopped.
There's 9/11, there's when Princess Diana died,
there's the OJ.
There's certain things like that,
but this is uniquely different from all of those
in that it is global and
is impacting all of us.
And there's never been an instance in which we had
to stay home and couldn't go about our day.
Yeah.
And I think with that it gives this experience
a certain quality that I think has the power to unite us.
There's a commonality of experience
that we're all sharing right now.
But I fear the divisiveness that I see.
And I think there's a certain kind
of toxic environment out there
that if we're not really paying attention to ourselves
and focusing on our priorities and really striving
to be that beacon that one could succumb to.
So there's these opposing forces of the kind
of unifying aspect of this that can be uplifting
versus this destructive force of negativity
that I see out there
as well.
Yeah, for sure.
I mean, we watched as a joke,
not as a joke but with intention,
but it was funny.
We watched "Groundhog Day" the other day,
the Bill Murray movie.
And it was weird because I've watched that a few times
but I never really took the message as clearly
as it was as when I watched it this time with regards
to how he was just being indifferent about everything,
right, and just smoking and doing all kinds of,
getting drunk and being a jerk.
But then once he started paying attention
to the lives around him and caring and giving,
he found fulfillment in that repetition, right.
He found love that finally broke the loop.
But fulfillment, despite the day continuing,
he was fine with it because he was giving
and he was focused on externally helping others
versus just focusing on what he can get out
of a day repeating itself over and over again.
But anyway, I mean,
it's Bill Murray, I mean,
you can get so much message.
But I thought it was interesting because here we are,
we're living a very similar "Groundhog Day".
I don't know how many times over the last few weeks I
have said, what day is it?
They all feel the same, right,
with the kids home.
There's no sort of weekend versus day.
But as soon as the process takes over,
like we were saying earlier,
and knowing what we need to execute on every day,
weather work, weather family,
whether training, whatever it is,
there's sort of a fulfillment in that repetition
that I've come to enjoy actually these last 10 to 14 days
of alright, accepting this is the process currently
and I'm going to make the best in the present moment
of this process.
It's really the only way, acceptance.
Yep.
Railing against what is will only lead
to resentment and frustration.
Yeah.
So to embrace what's happening
and shift your perspective and look at it as,
I think it helps to understand
that everybody's going through it.
You haven't been singled out for this experience.
It is helpful.
But the only way to find peace is through acceptance.
For sure. For sure.
Also, with regards to,
like, you were talking about being sort of stuck
with this lack of compass and direction currently
as we pull back to the training aspect
and the athlete aspect.
But the athlete's mindset is exactly that.
Like you said,
the awareness to stay in the moment
and do the best you can do at the task at hand,
whatever that task is, right.
If it's currently with my family
or currently at work or currently
in this process of training or currently going on a hike
and noticing nature around us like that,
that's all we can focus on.
And that's the best place to focus on
in the current moment,
in the present moment.
Yeah.
Have you had any athletes
that are just completely unraveling?
(laughing)
Yes. Yes, absolutely.
I mean, don't get me wrong,
I'm probably busier than ever currently,
just because so many are at home and, A,
have more time to train or, B,
a lot more ideas.
A lot more emails.
Exactly, a lot more emails,
a lot more phone calls.
I'm also taking this time,
like I was talking earlier,
of going over everybody's running form and cycling form
and stretch cord form or those that can open water swim.
And they're all sending me a videos,
so I'm going through that.
But there are definitely those who are completely
off the rails.
And there's those,
just as on the other end of the spectrum,
that are completely unmotivated.
It's like, all right,
well, I know I can get to a certain level of fitness again.
It's hard to argue against that.
The only part that I say there is that when we come out
of this in that future version of ourselves,
how long will it come to get back to par
and get to where you wanna get to,
versus staying somewhat close to par
and then just increasing the effort, the training,
the fitness, that piece that you wanna get to to your event.
Doubling up on that is a lot.
I mean, that's gonna take a serious long amount
of time if you take the next four months completely off
and do nothing.
So that's another thing to keep in mind.
There's a basic maintenance level
that our body can be just a few weeks removed
from getting back to basically par fitness,
being pretty fit but not perfectly primed for an event.
And that's sort of where we wanna bubble right now,
just below the surface of, okay,
I'm maintaining a healthy body,
that it is strong enough and healthy enough
in order to then up the training when that urgency,
when that time comes again.
The other thing that other athletes have noticed, Rich,
is that those that are completely over-trained
and keep adding stuff,
they're realizing by doing less
how much better they're sleeping,
how much better they're feeling.
They're coming out
of that fog.
That's interesting.
They're coming out of that fog of fatigue
for the first time going, wow,
I didn't even really realize how tired I actually was.
I'm like, there you go.
Yeah, that's great. Yeah.
I like that, yeah.
(dramatic swooshing)
It's been cool to kind of watch all these people take
what they're learning from your book and then sharing it
and seeing some of this stuff go viral.
Well, the thing is
that at one point,
if you had vegetables in your life and maybe it's too,
I'm not a historian
and I cheated my way through high school,
so I really don't know when.
But there was a point in time that if you had vegetables,
you either grew them yourself or you knew who grew them.
And fast forward today,
most people have no idea
where their vegetables are coming from.
They're getting them in the supermarket
and most of America is in food deserts,
so they don't even have the quality of vegetables
and produce in their supermarket.
So now we live in a convenience culture.
So when I was living in New York, San Francisco,
LA, there was always access to fresh produce either
in a farmers market or a health food store or supermarket.
I could always get fresh produce.
But when I went back to nature,
and in my community there's 600 people
in 100 square miles and there is no health food store
where where we live.
This power of empowerment and sovereignty
around sprouting was something that I couldn't believe it.
When I came up with this idea,
I thought that it was flawed,
like I must be missing something.
And that kind of led to me calling up Dr. Michael Greger,
and calling up Dr. Oz and calling up Mark Hyman
and Dean Ornish and Joel Fuhrman and Joel Kahn,
calling these people and saying, hey,
talk to me about sprouts?
And I even talked to Dr. Josh Axe who wrote the "Keto" book.
So some of these people were keto,
some were paleo,
some were functional medicine,
some were plant-based.
And the thing that they all had in common
they all loved sprouts.
And they all had good things to say about sprouts.
And that was after that part of my research was done.
I even spoke to Andy Weil, right,
who is hard to get a hold of.
And he loves broccoli sprouts.
And it was just like, wow.
Nobody's shit talking to sprouts.
There was nothing and I couldn't believe and Jujimufu
adds sprouts to every meal.
He's growing more sprouts than he can eat,
which is a big feat 'cause he eats 4,000 calories a day.
But he adds sprouts to every meal.
And I envisioned,
you talk about manifestation,
I manifested in my mind,
there would be a guy who you'd never
in a million years would eat sprouts.
This was a guy who you'd expect to eat a cow alive
and
now the guy is eating
spouts ever meal.
A super sprout guy, yeah.
Super sprout guy.
Yeah, well you look great.
I said that the minute that you walked in the door
and I probably saw you, like,
I don't know,
six weeks ago or something like that.
And I know that you've been running a lot
and you've been wearing the Vibram Five Fingers,
running out in the desert.
And you have a nice color to yourself
and there's a brightness in your eye.
You are, certainly,
if nothing else,
like a living embodiment of healthy lifestyle.
Your energy is infectious.
You have so much enthusiasm for this lifestyle
and the things that you talk about
and you talk about it so eloquently and beautifully.
And you are the ambassador that we need.
How are we gonna clone Doug Evans so he can go into all
of these communities and espouse the revolutionary benefits
of eating this way?
I mean, you have to plant a lot of seeds, Rich
The seed metaphor just keeps circling back here.
Yeah and look,
I think it makes sense.
And if you see,
I've been on Instagram for a while and I didn't engage,
I didn't do things,
but now people ask questions,
I'm responding to the questions.
The most amazing thing is I'm learning by having
to think through these corner case examples and
expanding my sphere from the community
of the collective intelligence.
And the fact that now all these diverse range
of people are now spouting and it resonates with them,
that's it.
So I think,
how do we do it?
It's like one person at a time.
I'll engage in a conversation with one person online
or physically or at the farmers market.
In the Joshua Tree Farmers Market there's a little couple
that sells microgreens.
And they're now selling microgreens
and they're selling my book.
Every week I'm giving them ideas of what to do
to make it easier for them to share the consciousness.
And people are buying the book.
It's so strange 'cause it was hard for me
to write a sentence.
Having barely gotten through high school,
writing a book.
For virtually no money,
writing the book and having that part was something
that was missionary.
And it's gotta be incredibly gratifying
when you see people that you wouldn't suspect
would be interested in what you have to say,
cottoning onto it and sharing it online's very cool.
I mean,
the idea and I had spoken to you that
I met Marianne Williamson.
Right.
And I'd listen to "Return to Love".
I had read "A Course in Miracles" and her ideals,
and she had talked about reparations as part of her policy.
In one part I didn't feel
like the spout conversation would pique her interest.
But the other part said,
I think this is so important
that can I infect her consciousness
with lighting this up for sprouts?
Like, is this important enough for her to take seriously?
And now I'm seeing this,
and I'm saying this knowing where we are today
in the world and what's going on,
this is one of the most important conversations
that people can have is about diet
and lifestyle and nutrition.
And I don't know how many of the people on your guests,
on your podcasts have talked about that decision
of what you put in your mouth and how it affects your life.
And if this could be something
for literally pennies a serving,
dollars a day to be able to up the nutrition
and level the game.
And if people can have better memory,
better energy, better fit.
'Cause there's all this unconscious bias.
There's all of this kind of prejudice and limitations.
And tribalism.
Tribalism, and this is unifying,
people around food and collectivity.
But what is the level of unconscious bias around people
that are overweight and obese?
And it's just another form of discrimination.
So this is, I think,
I could tell you the woman who
started, I village,
I forgot her name.
And she had been a long-term vegetarian.
And then when she took the company public,
she started to eat meat.
And she said,
I need to eat meat in order
to fend off the toxicity of the public environment
and all these other people.
Then she resigned and then she went back
to being a vegetarian.
The idea of the toxicity
of the aggression that I find I'm a much nicer person.
I don't get,
so I was trying to understand what you were saying.
Basically, you're saying,
she felt like in order for her to kind of compete
in this clawing world of masculine,
corporate executives, that she had to eat meat?
She had to eat meat.
To be at that level of consciousness?
Yeah.
She went, she reverted back to a more primal survival.
I didn't fully get that but it was something
that I just became aware of.
And then afterwards she went back to eating plants.
So I think that,
to answer, go back to the bigger question that you asked.
How does this happen?
It's one person at a time.
It's literally having conversations
and building a collective consciousness.
At some point
kale came onto the scene, right.
And kale is no more healthy than collard greens
or chard, right.
Yeah, but it became the thing.
It's so interesting that that was the one that got selected.
Yeah, and Brussels sprouts became a thing, right.
Did you see the Brussels sprouts thing?
Not like kale though.
Yeah, I don't. I don't know.
All these things.
Who are these publicists pulling the levers behind?
What's gonna be the thing?
There was an artificial organization
that I talk about in the book.
What?
A woman kind of created the
National Kale Growers Association and launched PR
and did all this stuff around kale as a passion project.
It was like her project and it ignited.
And I think that sprouts have been around
for a really long time.
My pitch, I pitched one publisher in New York
and I made the recipes and I brought her some seeds.
And there'd never been a book on sprouting
from a major publisher.
I mean, this is like.
So all these things were.
And now I think this is,
the time for sprouting has come.
(dramatic swooshing)
To be a Phoenix you gotta burn.
It's like the whole process of rebirth.
It's not easy. It's not painless.
(dramatic swooshing)
So the precipitating event for what led to
"Love Yourself".
Reinciting incidents.
Reinciting incidents, so what is it we call it
in chemistry when the reaction happens?
I had built a company.
I'd self-funded it.
This was gonna be my FU money company, right.
And I was doing very well.
I was actually taking away real business
from Google and Yahoo in a vertical no one ever done before.
I was pulling it off,
built a great team,
got the deals that no one could get.
It was like I was obsessed, right,
and I was built three and a 1/2 years
and then I'd ran out of money.
Building a tech company for three and 1/2 years,
you'd run out.
Self-funded.
Self-funded, right.
Pretty much everyone's gonna run out of money.
(Kamal laughing)
Except for a couple people.
Yeah, and I took investment and it was doing well
and then the whole thing blew up and I lost everything.
I lost my company but along with it I lost my sense
of self-worth, to put it mildly.
'Cause my company was my complete identity.
What I was doing was my identity.
I was depressed beyond belief.
I had no money.
I was living off credit cards.
I remember having to make some payroll on the side
to some of my employees off credit cards.
I was like, look man,
you bought me my crazy dream.
I can't have your wife and kids starve.
Wow.
And it was a,
rough would be an understatement.
There were times where I was,
like, look.
I remember looking at the Bay Bridge from my window.
I was so exhausted.
I was burnt out.
I was really sick, burnt out,
whatever they call it, adrenal fatigue,
all the works.
I went to some doctor who worked with me later on it
and I didn't have the strength to walk over
to the Bay Bridge and throw myself off,
otherwise I would have.
It was literally like that.
And I think it was the next night or the night after
that I remember getting up and
I was miserable.
I was, like, I can't do this.
I gotta get out of this.
I mean, again,
I get out of this and die trying, that's it.
I can't be in this space.
And I walked over to my desk and I have a journal
that I write in and in there,
and I still don't know where it came from,
I sat down and wrote a vow to myself.
Now, I do believe in the power of personal commitment.
Like if I make a commitment to myself,
I'm gonna keep it.
That's something I've had for a while,
something I've trained myself for a while.
But a vow,
I've never written a vow to myself.
I don't know where that word came from.
And then it was a vow to love myself.
It came in the moment.
I am not a guy who was thinking about, hey,
you know what I need,
you know what I really need?
I think I need to love myself.
That never occurred to me once.
But yet, in that moment that's what came out.
Where did it come from?
It was that deep stillness that runs the whole show.
Well, I think what is profound about it
is that destruction.
It's like what you said,
if you wanna be a phoenix you gotta burn.
Opportunity finds its moment in destruction, right.
And it's this grand opportunity to deepen your surrender
to something more powerful than yourself, right.
You're being asked to
prostrate yourself a little bit lower
to really give over your ego even more,
to humble yourself
and to
let go,
like you're being confronted with your character defects
in a really profound way, right.
So then you have to forgive yourself again
and you have to do it even more profoundly
than you had to prior.
Yeah, it's actually,
I'm learning, life,
it's like a building a startup,
excuse the analogy but no company just rocket ships straight
up to the right.
It's like, it's loops.
But there is something to be said about consistency
and what really matters.
Like fitness, right,
if you're not consistent in your practice,
it'll show, your body will show.
The same with the mind.
And the mind is actually more plastic,
more malleable than anything else,
yet, it's the one that we work on the least.
We really do.
Right.
We really overlook it.
That's starting to change.
It's starting to change but there's a lot
of stuff out there that's,
I don't know is effective or not,
there's a lot of stuff out there.
In the end it's gotta be something,
what is the best workout,
what is the best nutrition plan?
It's the one you can do consistently.
That's what you gotta go for.
It's consistently that gives you the results.
Let's go back to forgiveness for a minute.
I think that's an important piece in all of this.
So how do you think about and practice that?
Well forgiveness, there's two forms,
right, forgiving others and forgiving yourself.
The novel that I wrote, "Rebirth",
that's about forgiveness
but that's about forgiving my father after he died.
The whole journey while I walked a pale pilgrimage in Spain
and the result of that pilgrimage was I learned
how to forgive him.
Right, like 550 miles?
Yeah, Camino de Santiago.
And you know what it was?
In the end it was just realizing his humanity.
He was a human being, man.
You can't hold humans to do the criteria of god's,
but we seem to do that.
And this really, his humanity.
When you realize someone's humanity,
it's very easy to forgive.
But in order to do that
you have to transcend your childhood lens
on your parents, right,
and shift that perspective to see it
through the eyes of the parents.
Or to see the eyes of a human being looking
at another human being.
You can never completely remove that,
right, the parent.
But if you can just do human being to another human being,
that right away shifts it and you see their struggles,
even faulty decision-making or whatever,
but their struggles.
When you understand that,
forgiveness actually comes naturally
because you can't help it.
You kind of understand.
You don't have to accept it.
You don't have to say yes, I agree.
I'm glad you were that way.
And I'm glad you did X, Y, and Z.
Because forgiveness ultimately is freeing yourself.
Yeah, I think we look at it as a two-way street.
I'll forgive you when you ask me for forgiveness,
or you admit what you did and how you wronged me.
But ultimately, the person who's carrying the resentment
or the anger or that pain is the one who is suffering.
The one who is the object
of being not forgiven is often even unaware.
That's our irony, right.
So it's a self-inflicted harm.
I was at an event,
a thing last night.
It's another little group thing that I do that was created
by this organization called the Nantucket Project.
And they created these neighborhood,
they're called neighborhood projects where little,
small groups of people get together
and they watch a short film
that the Nantucket Project produces,
and then a discussion ensues.
Kind of like to create
greater community in our neighborhoods.
And the movie that we watched last night
in this group setting was a short documentary about
the genocide in Rwanda and how the president
of Rwanda was faced with this
prospect of how to repair his country in the aftermath
of this horrible tragedy.
And the story is told from his perspective
and also through the perspective of a perpetrator
of the genocide,
somebody who killed a lot of people,
and a woman whose family had been killed.
And ultimately, it's a story about
how these two people forgive each other.
Wow.
And it's incredibly inspiring and it left me thinking
about the incredible exponential power of forgiveness.
I think there's something beautifully transcendent
and unique about forgiveness
in that it holds this potential energy capacity
to be so incredibly transformative.
Maybe it's because it's rare.
I don't know what it is about it uniquely,
but to see that,
it's impossible not to be moved.
And it leaves you thinking about
the people in our own lives that we refuse to forgive
or the resentments that we hold on to about
how we've been wronged and the pain that that creates
and the impediments to moving forward that constructs
in our lives.
And also,
about the people that we've harmed
and thinking more deeply about people who might be out
in the world carrying that kind of pain over things
that we might've done.
Yeah.
And then forgiving ourselves, right.
To repeat and loop the mantra,
I love myself,
I think self-forgiveness is a subset of that.
Yeah, that's actually the other part of forgiveness,
right, self-forgiveness.
For me, what I've learned is start with the self first.
You work on the self,
the rest actually gets easier.
The rest just naturally starts to work.
And the same thing with here was like in this book,
I have a practice that I do in forgiving myself
and it actually works beautifully.
And it's a very practical practice.
Like everything, it's practical,
you can do it and you will notice the shift.
And what I learned was I didn't have that
in the original version.
What I've learned is,
if you're gonna make a commitment to love yourself,
you can do this practice.
You can't leave the past behind but leave the shackles
of the past behind.
And what you do is you forgive yourself
and then you start to love yourself.
That's almost like the step-by-step.
And it makes a huge difference.
(dramatic swooshing)
Yeah, it's wild.
You mentioned that there's a lot of history
behind why outdoor spaces have been considered off limits
to people of color.
It's sickening and disheartening to hear that.
I believe it to be true.
But I can tell you that I haven't spent a lot
of time thinking about why that might be.
Well, if you think about how the
national parks were formulated
and how that land was stolen from native populations
without regard to any of their history or their domiciles,
I mean, that's just one part of that.
And I also think of how,
just land in the US,
(Mirna chuckling)
ownership of land is very, very white.
Ownership of any sort of real estate or land is very white.
And so
when someone like me appears,
like, I look like I don't belong
because the ownership of land has been traditionally white.
And so, I mean,
there's the government,
there are private entities that are also responsible
for this sort of white washing of land in the US.
And then there's white supremacy,
white supremacist ideology
that has it that black people don't belong
and we are seen as nuisances
in many different types of spaces.
And there's research on that too
on blacks is a nuisance
in public spaces.
(Rich sighing)
It's so heavy.
It's really heavy.
You see, I'm smiling because it's so heavy.
And to have to think about that constantly,
and I do think about it constantly,
look, every second that I'm on a trail.
I mean, I may be smiling and I may be gracious and
affable, but I am always,
always thinking about whether or not people think I belong?
And is somebody gonna ask me a dumb ass question
or are they gonna say something stupid
or are they going to make me feel as though I'm not welcome?
I'm always thinking of that which is why I'm so effusive
with my cheer because I have to be.
Yeah, you feel like part of that is a defense mechanism
to put other people at ease which makes you feel more safe.
Absolutely. Yeah.
I mean, that's the story of every black runner.
Every single person who goes out and runs who is black,
we have to signal.
There's a term for it.
It's called signaling,
to signal to other people that we are safe to be around
and we are not a threat.
Yeah, you hear stories of black runners
who will wear a sweatshirt or a
T-shirt that has
From their college.
a fancy college name on it or something like that
to make white people feel like this person is not a threat.
It doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter what you put on.
Again, I'm always decked out in a latest gear, right.
(Mirna chuckling)
I wear bright colors.
I've got my running cap and my trucker cap on,
a race shirt or something that signals to people
that I'm a runner.
When I still lived in Georgia I was running
down my own street
and I was two miles,
I had done 14 miles
and so I was finishing up the last two miles
to do a 16 miler.
On my way back home a woman in a white SUV was coming
in the opposite direction and stops about a 1/4
of a mile away from me.
I'm slow, so it takes me a long time to do a 1/4 of a mile.
So I was still pretty far away from her.
So she stops,
she takes out her phone.
She's looking at me.
She's talking on her phone,
looking at me,
talking to her phone.
Again, I am really decked out.
I mean, sweaty,
(Mirna chuckling)
but really decked out in all my running gear.
And then she gets off the phone and slowly rolls by me
and looks at me and I wave,
I'm smiling, hey,
wondering
what the hell she was doing.
And you do that on purpose
because you know?
On purpose.
Yeah, okay.
And not even five minutes later a cop car rolls by
from that same direction that she had been going
and they slowed down,
rolled down the window,
look at me.
I wave.
In my head I'm, like,
what the fuck?
Right.
And that cop rolls away and then another one comes
from the opposite direction, slows down,
rolls her window down and then I wave again,
hey, have a good day.
This is in your neighborhood.
This is two miles away from my house.
(Mirna chuckling)
And in my head, I'm like,
I'm just running. I am running.
I did have a walking stick that I carried
because there were lots of dogs.
There were no leash laws where I used to live.
And so there were dogs everywhere
and so I would have to bang the stick on the ground
to get the dogs away from me.
And so,
but it was a very fancy carved walking stick.
(Mirna chuckling)
And so when I got back home, of course,
I posted this on Facebook because that's what I do.
And we had some laughs about it
and one friend called me a suspicious black lady running.
(Mirna chuckling)
SBLR.
(laughing)
I'm just gonna get T-shirts made.
But some other people sort of questioned
whether or not I looked dangerous
because I had a walking stick with me,
white people, of course.
Maybe she was worried,
maybe she was scared by the stick you were carrying.
I was, like,
in my pink shirt that I was wearing
and my Nathan Hydration Pack and my dirty running shoes?
I mean,
that's the sort of thing that I think gives people pause.
Yeah.
There's a sociologist named Dr. Rashawn Ray
who has done a study of why black people don't exercise
in certain types of neighborhoods,
because of perceived
danger for their person.
(Mirna chuckling)
And that's exactly it,
that's what it is.
We signal, we wave,
we smile, we are extra friendly and bubbly.
But it doesn't seem to matter.
Then you'd look at Ahmaud Arbery,
just running in a neighborhood.
Yeah, I mean,
as you're telling this story
I can't stop thinking about him.
Your story isn't that dissimilar from his.
It has a different outcome, obviously,
but the circumstances are related.
And you can't listen to the story you just told
without conjuring up what might have gone terribly wrong
because somebody is confused about who you are
and what you're doing.
And why I'm there.
Right. Right. Right.
Even though it's very clear.
(Mirna chuckling)
Yeah, your signaling couldn't be more clear.
And I'm just picturing you running,
like, what is threatening about that?
And what's going on with that person
in the SUV that they're feeling so threatened by you?
Where is that confusion emanating from?
And what's going on in their life,
what is embedded in their programming that perceives
that as a threat or something to be scared of?
White supremacy is embedded in their programming.
That's what exactly what that is.
So if someone's listening to this
and this is like their initiation into thinking
about this a little bit more deeply than they have,
where does that person begin if they can't be privy
to your training?
To my very expensive course.
(Mirna laughing)
Where do you direct those people?
(Mirna sighing)
I think you should be reading.
I think reading is really good.
Looking through all the checklists
(Mirna laughing)
of 25 resources for anti-racism.
Yeah, there's a lot of those
getting circulated around.
I think that's important.
I think it's a very,
very important starting point.
But I also think that you should,
and it's very difficult now,
but you need to broaden your circle.
You need to be proximate to different kinds of people
and start embracing their various identities.
Examine your own.
Examine the way in which you were socialized.
And then see other people,
see other's identities, embrace them,
welcome them into your life.
I think that's the way to go.
(dramatic swooshing)
When the kid showed interest in doing a podcast
which naturally made my podcaster soul weep.
'Cause she'd been on a few episodes of SModcast
in the past and stuff.
But when she was, like,
I'm thinking about doing a podcast.
I was, like, what?
Oh my God,
I know a thing or two about that.
I was so excited.
So when she narrowed it down and created
what we're calling the Vegan Abbattoir,
one of the first things I said is, like,
oh, you have to have Rich Roll on.
Yeah, cool.
And she was,
like, why?
And I was like, because in this space he's the guy.
I'd said, I did this podcast,
it's like a year ago and not a week of my life goes by
where I don't run into somebody who's, like,
oh, I heard you were on Rich Roll's podcast.
And it's always somebody I would never expect.
Like, it's not like my vegan friend who said that.
It's somebody says this and I'm like, what,
you as well?
There was a lot of reach in that podcast.
You got a big audience.
Yeah, I appreciate that.
I mean, that means a lot coming from you.
I mean, Harley,
do you understand what your dad created?
I mean, he is like the original.
There's like three generations of podcasting here
because your dad, Kevin,
was one of the very first, like,
way, way before anybody was doing it to jump in
and own the space.
And he really pioneered it and created.
Everything that's happened,
a huge debt is owed to you, Kevin.
You are so sweet.
Personally,
I wasn't super early into becoming a podcaster
but I was very early in terms of being a fan.
And your show was one of the very first that I cottoned
onto and it's been super inspirational to me.
And so it's cool to be here with somebody
who goes all the way back to the beginning.
I inherited that legacy and it's made me better
at what I do.
And now to see you stepping into it, super cool.
Thank you, I definitely explained how important he was
to the podcasting community many times.
And I actually was going to try to attempt
to do a podcast alone and then one day he came up
to the kitchen while I was making breakfast and he was,
like, so I have to be a part of it.
(Rich chuckling)
It wasn't quite like that.
I know it wasn't.
He was, like,
I'm gonna be really insulted.
No, you actually said,
you're going to make a mistake if you don't include me.
(laughing)
That was close to it.
That was, like,
all right, here we go.
But, I mean,
I'm honored and I'm now very excited
that we have this together.
But he did make sure to explain his importance
to the podcasting community to me and give his own feel.
That's so funny.
Look, you know how we were talking
about your father created something?
I created something at this table, Rich,
that I'm kind of wishing right now
I'd created a little differently when you call me out
in public and tell my secrets.
When I walked up in the kitchen, I did,
I was just, like,
look, kiddo,
I was thinking about it.
You can totally do a podcast by yourself and I applaud that
but it would be such a mistake for us not to do it together.
I was, like,
because I'm a vegan too and you flipped me to veganism.
Your vegan story changed my life
and so I know the podcasting space and I was, like,
and people would love to hear a dad
and daughter talking together and stuff like that.
I was, like,
I'm not telling you what to do but there's a marketing hook
here that's so
tempting.
You were threatening
me a little bit.
(laughing)
I wasn't like,
if don't do a broadcast with me you're out of this house.
That doesn't mean he's not right though.
No, he was right.
And I think at the time I was, like,
this is rude but
(laughing)
I had then realized how awesome it
would be to have it together,
but also how cool it is to have the perspective
of somebody who's vegan for their health
and somebody who's vegan for a completely different reason,
for animal rights.
So it has also just proved to be a really good combination
for different back stories if I were vegan.
So that's also really cool.
But I was hesitant.
Why, why were you hesitant?
I wanna hear more about that but my sense is as somebody
who's on the outside looking in,
and I'm just meeting you now,
is one of the incredible kind of beautiful benefits
of everything that has happened to you with the heart attack
and going vegan and all of that,
is what's occurred with your relationship.
This has really brought you guys close.
It's very sweet.
Thank you.
You got involved in this movement because of your daughter
and her insistence and now you're gonna do this podcast.
There's just such a bond there
that you guys can do this stuff together.
It's really cool.
Thank you.
And I say that somewhat out of,
I have a 16-year-old daughter and, I mean,
that age right now where she wants nothing to do with me.
I was, like,
what would it take for my 16-year-old daughter
to wanna do a podcast with me?
I was, like,
you would have to move heaven and earth.
I'm nearly 21 so just give it a couple of more years.
But it has been really cool.
It's been really special to be able to do it together
and I didn't really give my dad a choice at all
to be vegan.
I just, I was insisting upon it.
I was green rolled.
She's like, you're gonna go vegan,
and I was like, all right.
Yeah, no,
he didn't have a choice.
But initially you said two months or something like that?
Yeah, well
that's how I posed it.
At the time I said, yeah.
But I was never really gonna let that happen.
But I wasn't gonna be like,
please, right now commit to a lifetime of veganism,
because I thought I would scare him.
But I did just kind of pose it as a few months but,
I mean, it's been like two years now?
Over two years.
Yeah, I mean,
even you couldn't have imagined that he would
become like this, basically,
you're not like the new face of veganism,
like it or not, Kevin.
No, but she knew in flipping me that,
like, he'd be a good get for us.
I was, I was like this is important.
He's got a big mouth and he's always talking
about his interests and if veganism was one
of his interests,
that's good for me and my community.
So she kind of saw the benefit of that.
But I would like to believe at the heart of it,
she was just like,
oh my God,
I know a way to keep you alive.
I had almost died clearly because I was ingesting not
just animal food products
but far too many animal food products over the course
of a lifetime.
So even the nutritionists in the room at that point was,
like, a plant-based diet will bring your cholesterol down
and that's where she saw the opening and was, like,
yes, one of us,
one of us.
So I said, look,
I eat the way that I ate for 47 years.
I'll give this six months.
The least I could do is try your way for six months,
why not, and that was two years ago.
Let me see, February,
March, April,
May, June,
July, it's almost two and a 1/2 years ago.
Two years and five months ago.
And I haven't missed anything.
That's the question I get the most
from people about veganism.
It's just, like,
what do you miss, bro,
what do you miss?
Your daughter's not here.
What do you miss?
That's so shady.
Well, because they know that you're the decomisar
of all this.
As you said,
he was going vegan for life so they know now I
have two bosses in life,
not just your mother,
but also you.
Yeah, so it'll
have to go through me.
So when you're not around,
they're like, come on dude,
what do you really think?
And I honestly don't miss anything.
There's nothing that I'm,
like, oh man.
That's the thing that people are surprised about,
'cause they suspect that you're just walking
around craving in and out
all day long.
Yeah, like your whole life
you're like living a 1/2 or a 1/4 life
where I can't enjoy food anymore.
We live in California
and so they've got this veganism stuff down to a science.
It's dialed in.
Really tasty.
But even without that,
even if you're just like, look,
I can't go to some high-end restaurant
where they take a kumquat and turn it into a meatball,
so what do I do?
Beans and rice, man,
tastier than most stuff that I ate on the non-vegan side.
That's seriously my go-to.
For the last month that's all I've been counting.
I've worked hard on beans
(indistinct)
The last time I saw you was
at the Mercy for Animals Gala thing and you got up
to the podium to give away the Hero Award or something,
I can't remember what exactly the award was
that you gave away.
But you said something along the lines of,
if somebody had told me if I went vegan
I'd be sitting next to the Joker,
I would've done this a long time ago.
A long time ago, yeah.
You were sitting
I don't know
Next to Joaquin.
If he liked it.
Joaquin kind of was, like,
don't tell them I'm the Joker,
as if they didn't know.
As if everyone in the room wasn't like,
the Joker's here.
He's amazing.
But yeah, the benefits
that come with it.
Of course, the health benefits are number one
for me have been obvious.
I dropped a bunch of weight.
In my behind-the-scenes life
or that's not so obvious is my body chemistry
and I find that out when I go to the doctor all the time.
And Dr. Ladenheim's the guy
that saved my life, my cardiologist.
Every time I've gone for the last,
you know, you do six month interval checkups.
He's always, like,
whatever you're doing,
keep doing it.
And the first time it registered was when I went vegan
for two months and I went in for a blood test
and he was just, like,
oh my God,
everything is great except for your cholesterol.
And I was, like, well we knew that.
That's why I had a heart attack.
He goes, no, your cholesterol's in the toilet.
What happened, he's like,
it dropped out.
And I was, like,
I went vegan.
And he's going, well,
I gotta cut the meds in 1/2
because whatever you're doing is really doing the job.
And so I've gone back every six months for another checkup
and the last one I had was right when I got back
from the tour, so it was beginning of March,
right before everything went into lockdown.
And he was just, like,
your blood work is phenomenal.
And he even said,
'cause Harley always picks at him,
'cause early on I was, like,
I'm gonna go vegan and Dr. Ladenheim was, like,
you don't have to go vegan.
There's nothing wrong with meat.
Which is astounding to me.
He goes, just keep it in moderation.
He's like, there's nothing wrong with meat.
So he later was,
like, look,
fuck me, going vegan was the right move for you.
I can clearly tell.
So he has since, like,
tell your daughter she was right.
Yeah.